Aaron Sampson here with my thoughts on
Titan Falls frontiers edge dlc i started
playing titanfall a few days ago to get
ready to cover frontiers edge and you
know what this game still feels [ __ ]
great
there's no game currently out there that
nails such simple mechanics like
movement and weapon balance so well the
closest analogy for that feeling would
be hitting fresh powder on a snowboard
in Lake Tahoe but that's not why you
come back for DLC you've been there and
done that and if half-empty matches on
PC say anything you've moved on
so should you come back to a game for
three Maps respawn is hoping you do but
they've put together a black market that
isn't worth the exorbitant black market
prices this black market would see
playing for hours and still having to
sell 50 burn cards or just flat-out
selling 200 burn cards for a shot at
three random Titan themed ones that
you're probably gonna get anyway that's
just bad business
respawn can and should adjust the black
market I've got a lot of faith in the
company that described their shooter
mechanics based on how everything makes
a player feel and in turn change the way
that I view shooters but at launch the
black market feels like a card con so
are three maps worth ten dollars is more
of a good thing still a good thing or is
that Trump by the human tendency to get
desensitized to something and not even
because that something is bland it's
just you get used to the taste the
function of the new daily challenges is
supposed to be to spice things up but
regen already serves that purpose a
system that already teaches you to play
outside your comfort zone and in the
process earn different burn cards anyway
and on top of that regen is a real risk
it's a genuinely tough decision that you
might regret which is why you're so
invested in it so what do you get from
these maps that make things new well the
dig site gives you very fast last Titan
standing rounds but so does the core map
rise
this central mining machine has a fun
environmental hazard if you're being
dumb Haven has cavernous interiors
actually some of the best so far in
titanfall and its aerial routes have the
kind of perches that we're missing in
swampland in the last DLC the export map
has a Biddle evolution shoot this
conduit at Bravo and an overpass on the
map becomes electrified export also
hints it's some kind of story with these
robotic customs agent
all three maps have fantastic routes and
stellar design and I don't think that's
in question but in a strange way by
keeping the price of this DLC low in
order to eliminate barriers to entry
respawn is also taking themselves off
the hook to make even more maps and more
story content I'd actually pay more for
more I want to see the series grow and
explore a universe only hinted at
between rounds I want to fight on the
backs of giant creatures so huge they
screw up jump calculations I want to
fight on relic and finish around after
sliding down a zip line to the colony
map below I also want some really cool
new ideas save virally released weapons
dynamic time and whether dragons at
aggro and players when shot something
that makes me feel like I'm actually
playing a next-gen game in other words I
value innovation more than I value low
priced DLC so is titanfall frontiers
edge DLC worth it it's more of the same
great thing so if you're still in love
with titanfall then yes completely but
if the Magic's gone I'd wait for a
sequel